amy tenenbaum shook off the omicron
variant in january or so she thought a
few weeks later she developed breathing
problems then she collapsed while
walking home i had a really fast
rapid pounding heart even at rest
and
chest tightness chest pain combined with
other symptoms like constant fatigue
amy's long covet forced her to give up
her job as a server despite being double
vaccinated with no underlying conditions
she can barely walk forced to use a
wheelchair to get around
from doctors there's confusion they just
were kind of like well we can't help you
here we don't know anything about it
come back in a few years and maybe we'll
know more editor carlos hernandez
castillo a researcher at dalhousie
university castillo plans to analyze
brain imaging of long coveted victims
looking for patterns that could lead to
public health guidelines on treatment so
when somebody gets sick uh
the the people in the hospital know what
to do after and what they need to
analyze or like maybe test in the
patients to know if they need extra
treatment or like follow-up it's tough
slogging considering long-haulers suffer
from various combinations of more than a
dozen symptoms everything from brain fog
to unexplained bruising and rashes and
unshakeable exhaustion my speech will
change
i slur or
you can't articulate castillo hopes to
coordinate his two-year research project
with similar studies being launched in
toronto london ontario and in mexico we
need to combine data from different
sources to be able to find out those
patterns we want to make like a map of
exactly which functions are getting
affected from coming amy tenenbaum just
graduated from dalhousie she plans to
pursue a graduate degree her strength
wavering but her spirit unbroken
ross lord global news halifax